for me honestly right before that pilot
that I was just describing was was my
lowest and it wasn't oh my God I'm I'm
I'm dead in this business I'll never I
want to get out of it but there was the
fear that perhaps I'd had my run I had a
period of several years where things
were definitely had crested for me and I
had not given thought to any future and
indeed it put it highlighted the fact
that I hadn't given a lot of thought to
a lot of things that I'd done in my life
either professionally or personally and
it began a kind of a personal journey of
of trying to kind of take stock and and
change my ways and live with intention
so much my self-esteem had been tied up
in the affirmation that I received as an
actor and I had not thought that through
how shallow that is how superficial
ultimately that is because when that
goes away a sense of meaning left with
me and I and and the me that I was left
with was UN underdeveloped